le moment d'agir voilà le slogan la coop
25 qui s'ouvrait ce matin à madrid où
sont réunis une cinquantaine de chefs
d'état et de gouvernement pendant 12
jours pour tenter de trouver des remèdes
à un constat invariable la planète va
mal
camille guibert wallis de partir
surrender where do we really want bolt
c'était le secrétaire général des
nations unies ce matin à l'ouverture du
sommet c'était une marche en coop
après coop on entend systématiquement
les mêmes cris d'alarmé ce que vous
attendez un déclic cette fois ci alors
bon au risque de vous décevoir je ne
suis pas pessimiste je ne suis pas
pessimiste parce que lorsque l'on écoute
tout ce qui se fait tout ce qui se dit
toutes les actions qui sont menées y
compris les actions par des petits
groupes notamment les lycéens par
exemple en europe on voit bien que le
climat en terme de pression
psychologique globale augmente en
permanence
alors même si les actions politiques
sont décevantes même si la baisse des
taux d'émission est décevante
la réalité c'est que dans la fameuse
courbe en s qui traduit les innovations
et bien on est tout en bas mais bientôt
on va arriver dans la phase montante ou
la lutte contre le climat va devenir une
obligation et une action commune voilà
moi je pense ça et je veux penser ça que
je ne veux pas m'engager dans une
complainte permanente prêté ce que les
gouvernements ne font pas assez il n'y a
pas que les gouvernements qui doivent
faire les entreprises
certaines entreprises sont extrêmement
active et les citoyens sont de plus en
plus que j'allais dire exactement la cie
emmanuel barbaresques finalement il faut
juste rien attendre de ses confères
conférence des grandes conférences
internationales et juste penser à notre
échelle là je crois qu'il faut faire les
deux ces conférences sont une importance
capitale du fait de la pression de
l'opinion publique et notamment chez les
jeunes
il y à une incandescence de ces sujets
extrêmement extrêmement grande je lisais
que la semaine dernière en allemagne des
centaines de classes d'enfants marché
dans les rues pour défendre la planète
si je puis dire et sont peut-être des
enfants mais les les
les plus vieux de ces jeunes au parmi
lesquels je mets volontiers mes propres
enfants sont extrêmement j'allais dire
sont extrêmement concentrés sur cette
question au point que la politique ne
leur ne les intéresse que sous cet angle
là c'est à dire que les sujets divers
vins classiques si je puis dire sur
lesquels pour lesquels nous nous étions
éventuellement enflammé je parle du
xxème siècle en ce qui me concerne ne
les touche le nez touche pas ou beaucoup
moins sinon que celui ci et là il s'agit
véritablement d'une d'une démarche dont
il voudrait que et les les coptes d'une
part et d'autre part les gouvernements
les entreprises et c soit davantage soit
davantage j'allais dire sur la balle et
est de ce point de vue là il me semble
que la pression exercée sur les divers
gouvernements de ce fait là est assez
forte
georges quelques osmanovic à chaque fois
je est ce que vous êtes aussi positif
alors pas du tout en plus je travaille
par ailleurs sur ces questions là et les
rapports avant qu'ils soient tous
mensonge et du giec le groupe
intergouvernemental d'étude du climat
mandaté par l'onu ou ceux qui
considèrent que le giec parce que j'ai
que fait des rapports plus mesuré que la
réalité de ce qui se fait par exemple au
web haïti qui font des rapports qui sont
extrêmement catastrophique et il ya un
petit problème à ce jour là rebondir sur
ce que vous avez dit sur les jeunes qui
se mobilisent je pense à greta tube
merde quand elle est venue en france au
parlement français et s'est retrouvé le
jour de la ratification du sénat
une farce en fait à laure délié des
jeunes se mobilisent et on les utilise
comme on utilise l ce jour là alors
qu'on encore une fois ratifié c'est
assez compliqué nous qui ouvre à
encore plus libre échange la
surconsommation là le transport de
marchandises sans aucune régulation
possible par les états et là il ya un
souci c'est à dire qu'on a une sphère
pour faire pour faire bref cascades
écrit carl polony on a une tendre un
transfert de pouvoir entre le bleu le
public au privé on a des mastodontes
tels comme les gaffes à aux états unis
sur lesquels les états unis les états
unis l'état américain ne peut pas
imposer la loi antitrust qu'il avait
imposé la standard oil droxler un siècle
avant c'est une telle puissance
comment comment on peut contraindre ceux
là même qui ne fonctionne que par
l'accroissement permanent de l'activité
économique et de leurs profits aucun
souci et nous dans notre mouvement
république souveraine on voit les
questions de c'est une autre manière
ça nous semble depuis 92 rio en fait en
réalité rien ne se passe même s'il ya
une effectivement une conscience de plus
en plus accrue chez les jeunes mais
concrètement il se passe pas grand chose
et il est temps que ceux qui dirigent
notre pays la france se préparait peut
se prépare à la résilience car qu'on le
voit bien on a tous les tous les ans
vingt départements qui déborde
là c'est le var c'est tout le temps tous
les ans il ya des problèmes qui vont
s'aggraver et il faut qu'on ait un pays
qui visiblement on n'arrive pas à agir
de manière globale faut au moins qu'on
puisse se défendre et se résister vous
comprenez pas aussi un petit peu ce qui
freine les états unis qui privilégient
leur leur industrie le la pologne qui
est encore au charbon parce qu'elle veut
pas importer de gaza ont dit ils sont
égoïstes on comprend pas du tout non
mais c'est les états unis on sait que
c'est un problème depuis la cap 21
c'était pas trump c'est john kerry qui
était là il a dit c'est charles jude ils
pouvaient pas signé si on écrivait
charles temps une contrainte il faut
chaud john kerry a dit la même chose que
bush des choses que trump
on ne peut pas changer notre mode de vie
donc c'est un mode de vie où 85% de la
population mondiale consomme 40% des
ressources un enfant maîtrisant un petit
peu les outils mathématiques comprends
que ça va pas tenir longtemps
surtout si on étend ce mode de
consommation réseau plein axe jean
daniel lévy
on vient de le dire la jeunesse la
différence avec les présidents de coop
c'est que la jeunesse s'est mobilisé
entre temps il ya eu beaucoup de marche
ces derniers temps pour dire justement à
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir d'agir
est ce que on sait quelle place va avoir
l'écologie dans les prochaines échéances
électorales
déjà c'est la jeunesse européenne c'est
pas forcément la jeunesse au niveau
mondial et on voit bien que dans
certains pays qui sont fortement
producteurs d'énergies carbonées qui a
pas de mobilisation extrêmement net on
peut le voir en urbaines européennes
urbaine notamment urbaines et un peu
plus diplômés avec eux à la moyenne
parce qu'en fait donc partie de la
jeunesse ne s'est pas portée par exemple
verts europe ecologie les verts au cours
des élections européennes lorsqu'on se
projette pas des prochaines élections
municipales
c'est vrai qu'à thématiques écologiques
envers le mental est forte ça fait
partie de la première ou deuxième
motivation de vote de l'ensemble de
l'électorat
sachant que il ya la perception qu'on
est face à un enjeu est un enjeu mondial
qu'on n'a pas forcément toujours la main
pour pouvoir mener une action au niveau
international donc chaque individu se
dit comment moi même je peux faire en
sorte pour que au moins j'ai la bonne
conscience d'avoir fait quelque chose et
pouvoir dire à mes enfants
eh ben j'ai fait ce qui était mon
possible d'où l'idée de pouvoir réduire
la place de la voiture d'où l'idée de
consommer de manière générale un peu
différemment d'oublier de l'organisme et
indignation entretien filmé temps passes
tu dis on doit évidemment consommer
moins et mieux
et puis surtout recyclés et puis réparés
oui c'est ça en fait en tout cas ma
route que cette tendance se respire à
sion elles existent nettement elles
existent de la part des français
n'existe de la part des jeunes elle
existe un peu plus de la part des
personnes qui sont les plus à l'aise
économiquement et surtout les personnes
qui sont les plus diplômés ou qu'ils
soutenaient qu'ils disposent des plus
hauts des plus hauts niveaux de revenus
et une sensibilité complémentaires
acquis bien savoir à ça c'est la
question la santé pas uniquement ce
moyen ou long terme est en train de se
dire peut-être qu'elle à travers le
dérèglement climatique peut être qu'avec
les enjeux écologiques normalement tôt
je peux avoir des problèmes
immédiatement en matière de santé donc
qui peut avoir des effets sur quel type
de pression comme être sur l'industrie
aujourd'hui notamment l'industrie
agroalimentaire
comment je fais pour moi même ma part et
de différents sujets pour modifier
globalement le comportement il ya des
applications qui sont utilisés de
manière extrêmement l'aide par les
français pour s'assurer que soient pas
ni mauvais d'un point de vue écologique
est dans le mental n'est ni mauvais d'un
point de vue global en matière de santé
sur le figaro.fr tell me dis la france
n'en fait pas assez car elle n'oriente
pas sa politique de la bonne manière par
exemple le train reste hors de prix et
puis nicole nous dit les débordements
dans le var ne sont pas dus au
réchauffement mais plutôt à
l'urbanisation intense et babineau là
comme 25 est une campagne de
communication une perte de temps et
d'argent
les gouvernants devraient plutôt agir
mais alors stéphane marchand comment on
fait un capitalisme vert alors c'est il
ya beaucoup de gens qui disent que le
capitalisme vert est une sorte de
contradiction dans les termes
et ils prêchent la décroissance glisse
que la croissance verte est impossible
c'est un mensonge
en réalité c'est un mensonge
karl marx annonçait la fin du
capitalisme assez rapidement eh bien il
avait négligé la puissance de
l'innovation et les incroyables gains de
productivité qu'on allait faire il ya
des gens qui ont prévu qui auraient des
famines il n'avait pas prévu que la
productivité agricole allait faire des
projets compte des progrès considérables
donc moi je suis optimiste je pense que
la technologie va résoudre une grande
partie du problème climatique mais
évidemment c'est lent c'est très long
mais ça a déjà commencé il ya il ya
encore ya cent ans on mourait du
brouillard à londres il ya même pas son
temps d'ailleurs un peu moins en 1950 je
crois aujourd'hui on ne meurt plus du
brouillard à londres donc il ya des
progrès qui sont faits et l'avenir n'est
pas entièrement sombre la mire seulement
on atteint le nirvana lentement
lentement mais et pour ce qui concerne
la communication
moi je suis pas pour la communication
mais c'est quand même en la matière
extraordinairement important qu'il y ait
une communication intelligente et à la
fois exigeante et positive sur ces
sujets là imaginer qu'il ait pas du tout
communication langois serait bien pire
georges kuzmanovic est ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer y en a qui préconise qu'on
fasse un espèce de clubs de pays qui
mettrait en place
le prix du carbone une sorte de tarifs
douaniers sorte de protectionnisme
ça va tellement à l'encontre de toute la
logique du système économique actuel que
ça me semble compliqué par contre il
faut bien se rendre compte que le
problème du climat c'est un trop fort
taux de concentration de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
c'est ça le problème quel que soit le
système économique dans lequel on est
qu'il tentera de résoudre ce souci
il faut savoir qu'actuellement c'est 80%
de l'énergie c'est l'énergie qui
proviennent des hydrocarbures à la seule
solution technologique actuellement
existantes c'est le nucléaire pourquoi
pensez on voit et à la une contradiction
chez certains verts en particulier en
allemagne où ils ont abandonné la
production nucléaires sur leur
territoire
ils ont rouvert des centrales à charbon
parce que l'énergie faut bien produire
visiblement les éoliennes ne suffisent
pas pu toutes façons ils ont un coût
environnemental
or s'il est actuellement la seule
manière à production d'énergie constante
et je vois très mal en fait l'humanité
reculé sur sa consommation d'énergie
surtout qu'une population mondiale et
qui croient évincé le nucléaire et je
suis très surpris que ce gouvernement
est arrêté leurs recherches sur les
générateurs de quatrième génération qui
fonctionne sur le sur les justement des
déchets nucléaires et ne pousse pas plus
les recherches et les moyens sur la
maîtrise de la fusion nucléaire civil si
si ça si on pousse pas dans ce sens là
je vois mal une solution sérieuse
qu'elle quelle soit contre le co2 dans
l'atmosphère
sur le figaro.fr pardon mais sur le sur
les productions de gaz à effet de serre
elles sont en augmentation de 1 5%
depuis dix ans et l'europe
enfin s'agissant de l'europe qui occupe
la troisième position 2
meilleur le plus grand pollueur mondial
voilà donc on a du travail à d'évidence
on a du travail et je crois savoir que
la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen présente
son son plan climat le 11 décembre dont
elle dit que ce sera la priorité pour
les années qui viennent
donc voilà enfin il faut quand même
bouger en en parlant davantage à toutes
les strates du système parce que parce
que si si le nucléaire est une réponse
pendant ce temps là on a des productions
de gaz à effet de serre gigantesque donc
c'est vrai que à un moment donné pour
vouloir faire quelque chose en fait
nicole vous interpelle sur figaro elle
vous demande si ces coptes sont vraiment
écologique quand on voit le nombre
d'avions pour transporter tout ce beau
monde et nous vous poser la question sur
lefigaro.fr depuis ce matin la france en
fait est là c'est pour limiter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
vous étiez c'était assez serré puisque
vous étiez 54 pour 53% à nous dire que
oui alors ce sont plusieurs millions